dans une heure nous arriverons sur la
place de john terry
[Musique]
aucune formation dix jours et pour
certains encore moins ces jeunes ne
savent pas que c'est une mission suicide
n'est ce parti
comment comptez-vous apporter votre
soutien aux troupes envoyées à zhang
sarine je suppose que vous n'allez pas
les laisser tomber
l'armee coréenne est en route vers le
nord pour nous attaquer
je ferai tout ce qui est en mon pouvoir
pour que personne ne meurt sur cette
plage c'est le mieux que je puisse faire
pour l'instant
[Applaudissements]
tous les élèves peuvent d'abord palais
en politique on doit en paix ensemble je
vais faire en sorte que le monde entier
soit au courant de cette guerre de corée
[Musique]
arrêtez pas